I identify as jacked handsome
and wonderful and successful those are
my preferred adjectives
right
you will hurt my feelings if you don't
refer to me as jacked handsome
intelligent charming and so
I I don't have you have a right to
freedom of speech I don't have a right
to control your language
that's not how it works there's no
there's no right to not have your
feelings hurt there's no right to
control other people's language the
right is on the other side so yes people
should be polite and kind and civil
within reason but actually if you are
now trying to control someone else's
language and force them to call you
something especially something that you
are not you don't have a right to do
that at all at all that's not all right
if I turn around I said you
from today I'm going to be a virgin
um forget about don't worry about the
three grandchildren I'm a 36 year old
son I'm gonna be a virgin and I'm not
going to and anybody else who says to me
that I'm not a virgin I'm gonna sue them
I'm going to go to newspapers and I'm
going to make I'll be up in ours because
I am now identifying as a virgin
and I and I said to you you have to see
me as a virgin would you feel happy
about that but I think we keep creating
examples that are not very relative to
this conversation obviously being a
virgin that is a very objective thing
someone identifying as a man or woman
we've not been able to identify it we've
not been able to explain what a man and
a woman is there was
when did you start believing what you're
saying now
when I started listening to people
no no no honestly when when like when
specifically did you start I would say I
had to be I've always grown up
let people be
they want to believe and let me explain
okay I'm a minority right being black in
the UK especially I know how hard it is
when the majority think that you are in
the wrong and maybe that is that
compassion that I have for them because
we are the majority we have the
privilege because we were born as our
gender so we have the privilege to say
no that's how you everyone was born as
their gender no no the gender that we
identify as but my point is that we are
the privileged to be able to say that
that is our identity however some people
don't have that and I feel like being a
minority and knowing what it feels like
for somebody to be like no you're less
than or no exactly okay so someone's
saying that's the way it should be no I
have a problem with that because well no
if I was on the other foot and I was
born as a as a man and I want to
identify as a woman I would be pissed
off if somebody told me that I can't be
what I want to be nobody's saying that
nobody's saying that nobody's saying
that well you are because I'm not saying
I'm saying you are not object you are
objectively not that thing if you if you
were sitting here telling me that you
are white
right I'll be like you're you're not
white you you can say that you are you
can feel like it you can act like it
whatever that means you could even go
and bleach your skin you could you could
do whatever you like you have the right
to do that you're an adult you have the
right to do whatever you want you can
have cosmetic procedures you can do what
you like but you are not you are not
white objectively you're you're not like
that that's the thing you know identify
this identifying thing it opens up an
entire Pandora's box of anything because
you can identify as as anything right
and as I said I support someone's right
to live their life as they want to I'm
not gonna treat I know more trans just
because I know so many people period I
know more trans most people don't know
any transgender people I know multiple
transgender people right
um and I will treat any human being with
respect and dignity and civility what I
will not do is distort the truth and lie
to make someone
feel happy and you don't and you don't
need to do that right you can you can
you can respect people and be kind and
be honest and also protect the truth
but is it the truth though that's what
I'm trying to say because how do you we
humans are so complex but see I agree
with you but this is not the truth no
in reality is not no it's not it's it's
difficult no it's not it's not hypocrite
the reason I ask why you I I'm assuming
you only started believing what you're
saying quite recently
I personally I've never read I don't
know when I started believing it I think
I've always just grown up with like I
said be whatever struggles are not
hurting anybody when you were 15. okay I
don't think I ever thought about it okay
I guess the conversation is coming up a
lot more of course and I decided I'm not
going to tell someone how they feel I'm
not going to do that because what who am
I to tell you that you're not a woman
wait
the same person you wanted to say that
this table is not circular in yellow
objective we humans can't be objective
every in everything that we do we can't
be objective we're too complex can I
just say okay he was bringing up about
being black and how you're used to
people you know your raised being black
and being down children so you
understand how they feel
you didn't choose to be black
That's the Way You Are
they're choosing to change their sex
Y no well they believe that
they can believe that I'm white
[Laughter]
find anything that does not work
there's so many different things oh and
then you can turn around and say that I
can say that and why I'm speaking like
this what am I going to get called
coconut but nothing's going to change
I mean some some men are you know five
foot four and they'd much rather be six
foot four can a man identify as six foot
four he could genuinely feel he could be
very confident and I feel like I'm in
the wrong body I I'm six foot four but
you are objectively not six foot four
you can feel like you're judged by like
the way you look we can actually like
measure you you don't look six foot four
you can we can take a cell from any part
of a woman's body and look at it under a
microscope and you can see chromosome
that's a woman absolutely yeah but that
General woman that gender person don't
look like a woman
are you questioning are you questioning
that it's not chromosome no no I'm not
saying that it's I just think that's a
factor of as a woman I think some people
yeah you can be a man you can't have the
XX chromosome and guess what you could
grow up be more masculine than anyone
but that doesn't make you doesn't make
you a man a man you can be a masculine
you can be a feminine man just because
you have your XY questions I don't want
to be broke but sometimes
create you that way just because you
didn't have the XY chromosome just like
just because you can't reproduce
it doesn't like it doesn't Okay can I
ask a question why would it be important
to that person for me to
believe and so-called affirm their
delusion validation that's delicious
because you keep calling it a delusion
that's the problem if I came in here if
you actually changed the way you're
talking about wait wait wait look if
let's be real if I said that I was six
foot five
right no if I said I am six foot five I
have okay and I insist on it and I get
triggered I get mad I'm trying to get
everyone to say I am six foot five right
am I is that is that a delusion
is
that me being reasonable am I am I being
the reasonable one by trying to force
everyone to accommodate that is that me
being reasonable
um are they being unreasonable by by
saying no you're not okay you can
measure that you can tell very easily if
someone is male or female with 100
accuracy if I walked in here and said I
identify as you're 26 right I identify
as being 26.
that like you can't measure but I could
just go around and by the way that's and
by the way that's much more valuable
than you said yeah but you know but you
know
whether you're male or female
but ah I don't know so I could identify
and say look you know I feel more that
I'm I'm your age I'm 26. so my brain
could be living in the past of I'm 26.
it's registered on my birth certificate
just the same as being a female is
and by the way there is such a thing as
uh you know biological age in terms of
your health and other factors so you can
be 40 years old but sort of have a
biological age of 32 say if you're in
very good shape and so on so again we
could argue that can I just make a point
to that sure when
created and identified as men and women
we haven't really understood humans
we're only understanding things now okay
what's considered a mental what do you
mean by understanding humans like what
does that mean we had a one way of
thinking about things so because your XY
chromosome you have a vagina you're a
woman but now we're starting to see that
that's not the case we need to adapters
what do we want them to do no are we
just going to say all of them have
mental conditions
if I started going around and saying I
am black I am black you wouldn't think
something's wrong with me you wouldn't
think I'm delusional yeah but that's
categorized what do you mean male and
female is a category we have bathrooms
male female
like what if what if I use that same
argument what if I use that same
argument okay and I said well all
throughout all of history we've known
what black and white is and now today
we're going to change it and now I am
black can I just want something if he
was in the sinking ship and they said
Women and Children First are trans
you know this happened in Ukraine really
yeah because you know in Ukraine the men
were not allowed to leave oh yeah that's
right and there were uh men who
identified as women who were trying to
leave and they were like no you know
Women and Children First
and somebody identifies big Butch
identifying a woman says hey I'm before
you how would you feel that yeah we know
the past said would you so I have a
question I have a question
[Laughter]
you're in a school you're you're a
mother
yeah you've got children
and they're in they're in school and
they're teaching about transgender and
your child your son comes home and says
right mum I need the girls school
uniform because today I'm identifying as
a girl we talked about gender and I
realized I don't want to be a boy I
don't want to wear trousers I want the
girls school uniform little pretty
Philly socks and I'm now a girl mum
I mean it will be very difficult for me
to understand but I will be open-minded
enough to understand why my child has
come to that decision I think just being
close-minded to me completely that is
not allowing people to live
it's not being close-minded because
there's a dollar to school like that
would you allow your son to wear a dress
to school initially probably not can I
just say why not because I grew up in a
very traditional household is that being
I was minded though yeah I do think
being traditional is quite close-minded
because you're not trying to understand
people I'm not saying I'm so for it like
be transgender I'm just saying I am
willing to learn I am willing to listen
to how you feel why you feel it I want
it to be more studies I want us to be
more so I have a question but at what
cost
thank you
um okay so at what cost and what I mean
by that is okay it starts with you just
say they're gender pronouns when you
meet them right and you just treat them
as the opposite like I don't know
whatever they're pretending to be that
day but but would you be cool with them
playing in women's sports
transgender and then what if what if at
now we don't have women's sports because
my deadlift record hold I mean in terms
of that I do think this should be a
whole different category for them just
because I think it's quite unfair for a
man that now identify as a woman to then
say that you want to but yeah I know but
because we've already had a
long-standing
um definition in terms of sports like I
like the way that you participate in
terms of hormones as well men are
stronger so this is a woman
I think they should just be we should
just allow them to be understood so
creating a whole new category for
transgender I'm for that because you
know what that's what they feel like so
compete with that but that's not what
they want because they want to be
accepted 100 and affirmed 100 as women
and if you're going to do that you now
have no rational argument to prevent
that male who identifies as a woman from
Computing in women's sports because
that's now a woman I mean I think there
definitely needs to be more studies
because in terms of what study do you
need like I'm sorry no no I'm serious
okay I just feel like I just feel like
like what study do you need like what I
don't give a damn what study they put in
front of me if I see a dude that's 6'4
jacked and looks like a dude acts like a
dude Walks Like a Dude talks like a dude
and then is competing in the woman's
swimming category I don't need a study
to tell me that's a dude as many of you
know I was just banned on tick tock talk
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible